こんにちはスティッカーふぇんですそれじゃあ
ことなの勉強の子つーの
第2位
ですが
え
非常に大切なその
4層がですね
私はいつもいいんですけれども
あの言葉の勉強というのは
園生
学問的なちー滝なものじゃなくて
どちらかというと感情的なものです
もちろん
言葉を覚えるけれども覚えるよりもなれる
でそのもしその感情的につながってないならばなれるのは非常に難しい
だから
まあ日本でよく日本行くとですね本屋さんいくどですね
東4とかと行く関係の方もたくさんある
そして遠い区のなんかまあ私もたくさんそういう本も変えましたけども
toeic の単語と行くの文法書のターマー
重々的に読む人も
いつも日本でう私は見ますけどもそれが非常に難しい
これが硬く言葉を攻めていく方法なんですよ
それよりも柔らかく感情でつながる形でおぼ覚えておかないとダメなんですよそれは
具体的に言う
道
面白い
内容面白い本
非常に聴きやすい
好きな声を聞く
好き名前を大きく非常に感情的にですね
つながりがコネクションができるような材料を使って勉強するのが非常に以上に大切
例えば号 are you
そのフェーズだけの本だとか
文房のだけの本を3日にですね読んでもそういうビル行ってもですね
なかなか入り込まないんです
それよりも柔らかくてたくさん聴いて楽しいもの
聞きたいからまた聞くその読みたいからまた読む
そういうようなものを主に使って勉強しないといけません
もちろんその中には勉強してる人の方が
そのなんて言いますかね指導権を持っています
だから選ばないといけな私はこれを聞きたい
これを読みたいあるいはもっと根本的な6事を言うとですね
英語を並びたいそれだけ
主導権を取らないといけませんそしてあのぬん
並びたいだけじゃなくて絶対成功できますそれやる価値がある
絶対そのできます今
読んでる使っている
材料は好きだとそういうふうなね
その積極的な感情がないと成功するのは非常に難しい
で
まぁ僕の場合はへ
15か国語を勉強した中でいつも楽しくその言葉を勉強するんだけじゃなくてその言葉
を通じて
他のことそれはその国の文化歴史
あるいはその国の人とその会いたいとかそういうことをはあって
まあいつも楽しく勉強してきたわけですよ
だからまず今日のビデオだけではですねその
あの主張したいのはその4道県ですがその勉強する人が
積極的にそして楽しい事正しくないとやめたほうがいい
今読んでレッスンは分からないけれどもつまらないかもやめたほうがいい
そして
その何が読んでるを聞いてるとですねそれ楽しければですね声が聞きやすいと全部
わからなくてもいい
また繰り返して聴いてもいいしそれがもう
つまらなくなりましたからじゃ所着の劣勢に行きましょうとそういう自由自在で
楽しく勉強することが非常に大切です
距離が今日のポイントです次のビデオではあの言葉らべきの他のその側面からまた説明
して
やりますからじゃ皆さんどうもさようなら